hang on someone 31 31
3100 where is this guy he has
a bunch of rating for me no i can't lose
him
where are you where are you very
disappear
ah it's francine
29 oh let's go
d6 so we know our maneuver
this was in january that doesn't matter
if that wasn't jane why did he lose
no it's not a serious game it's like uh
a rating here for free okay
let's play knight f6
the guy came to share some rating with
me i'm pretty much sure
what do i do right now okay i think i
make a castle finally
so bishop h3 knight g4
well it's normally that's good when we
win uh
a bishop for a knight
it gotta be in our favor
so right now let's let's play five i
guess
5 might be a poor move actually
i don't really like it
okay so c5 so we close the center
yeah e5 was uh a5 is just a shame
this is just a shame
uh does he want to keep
his knight alive
hmm
i don't know let's play six
oh he used to knight a live uh the
bishop alive sorry but
who knows well okay of course i messed
up so badly
now i guess i gotta take
and retreat
let's go h5h4 and knight h5
okay i just blundered the pawn and he
didn't spot it
okay that's fair enough
that's the level of 3100 on just24
but he's uh well his positional concept
is fine
that's for sure
yeah 97 i get a protected square
now let's go b5
i i even missed the freaking b8 square
oh
dear what's going on
okay it's never like it's never led to
uh you know learn from your mistakes
okay k96 now he has just a
good passive pawn but who cares
who the hell cares did they see
okay g4
hmm
a weird move i want to keep my rook here
i don't afraid of getting waited
probably that's
uh that's my bad but i guess
i gotta be fine
so this green shade queen h6 is just a
check
that's my point
okay it's a free a free knight that's
good
it's a free queen
[Music]
yeah plus 17 thank you so much thank you
so much like
what could i do without you i i would
never win so much rating for one game
frankly speaking